thank you very much everybody the  question was asked just a little while  ago about supporting the people  protesting in Iran and are going through  a very tough period and we do support  them totally and have supported them  from the beginning the question was  asked do we support them  I thought financially and we haven't  supported them I don't know that we've  ever been actually asked to support them  financially and I you know somebody  asked maybe we would but we support them  very very seriously the people that are  protesting in around Allah that freedom  and we are fully in support of them so I  wanted to just in case anybody had any  questions we haven't been asked to  support them financially which I assume  that is what the question was just to  make sure everybody understood it  you